hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is the iPhone 6 it's finally here
the iPhone 6 and 6-plus came out at the
same time and I'll be covering the six
plus a little bit later but I figured I
would give you guys my first impressions
my first thoughts on this new iPhone
form factor I've a lot to say about the
hardware iOS 8 is also now on this guy
but I'm not gonna do an unboxing I'm
pretty sure you've already seen what's
in the box with a new iPhone so let's
just get straight into my thoughts on it
so if Apple was going for the world's
most minimal smartphone packaging I
think they've nailed it here although
they totally could have just run out of
printer ink or something but either way
those stuff you get inside the box is
about the same as any other iPhone so
there's that in fact the one thing that
actually did notice about the packaging
was a special cut out for the iPhones
new protruding camera but we'll get to
that in a second so this is the iPhone 6
and it's probably going to look very
familiar from the 4.7 inch screen size
to the design to the thinness and the
button placement if you guys remember
the video I did on this silver iPhone 6
dummy
earlier this year this new phone
actually matches that dummy in a lot of
ways almost to a tee with the ports the
camera flash and everything even the
paint on the back around the antenna
which I didn't exactly think was legit
is exactly the same here and this looks
a little different on the different
colored iPhones I think it looks much
more subtle on the space grey but this
happens to be the gold ones so the paint
lines stick out a bit more I hope to get
another subdued look on a different
color iPhone very soon but my immediate
impressions with fuel in the hand is
this phone first of all it's strikingly
light like really really light much
lighter and of course thinner than the
iPhone 5s it's actually only a hundred
and twenty-nine grams which is crazy
light in the smartphone scale things and
another crazy measurement is it's
freaking thin it's 6.9 millimeters thin
now here's the thing about the iPhone 6
is thinness all of this comes with the
trade-off of number one a small battery
again and number two the protruding
camera lens out the back it might not
seem like a big deal at first but you'll
hear a lot of other people talking about
this sticking out the back means the
phone won't sit flat on a table anymore
it means the lens will be the first
thing to scratch that's it's sticking
out the back it's protruded it's on
protected and it's just unsightly it
doesn't look as good I don't think I can
possibly be the only one who would
rather just have a slightly thicker
iPhone 6 so that the camera doesn't
stick out and the battery is bigger but
you know maybe iPhone 6s either way the
thing about this phone is the rounded
edges remind me a lot of the HTC One m8
in that in adding all metal and rounding
it around here it makes it a lot
slippery or compared to the predecessor
so basically the iPhone 5s you had that
flat edge that you could hold on to and
manipulate the phone in your hand
however you want it was a lot easier but
what the iPhone 6 being rounded off I
feel like it's a lot easier to slip or
fall or drop without a case and it's
funny because someone has actually
already dropped their iPhone on day one
but that's another story
on the front of the iPhone 6 is the main
story which a lot of people are talking
about is the big feature it's a brand
new 4.7 inch display is not the 5.5 inch
of the iPhone 6 plus but it's a modest
improvement here over the 5s and it has
this odd resolution Apple calls it
retina HD but that doesn't really matter
it's 1334 by 750 so in reality just a
little bit above 720p so it's the same
pixel density as the iPhone 5s and it is
a pretty nice-looking display it's very
very bright outdoors it can get very
very dim indoors
it's basically what we'd come to expect
from Apple and their integration it's
it's great viewing angles great color
reproduction from what I can see it's a
great Apple display of course the bezels
around the display are a little bit
bigger than some other phones like the
Moto X for example that also have a 4.7
inch display since Apple needs room for
the home button and a matching forehead
for the chin so it's up to them to
decide when they want to slim down the
bezels but right now it's definitely a
nice size bump compared to other 4.7
inch screen phones so iOS 8 seems to do
just fine with this new resolution in
fact I think iOS 8 is the first version
of iOS to not stutter when I pull down
into spotlight search that might be a
minor thing for most people but that
always stuttered before iOS 8 so I was
pretty happy about that on the iPhone 5s
and I'm pretty happy about that on the
iPhone 6 I know but it's definitely
going to be fun to play around with iOS
8 a bit more obviously a bunch of other
phones have this now on other iPhones
but I actually made a video a while back
about my thoughts on iOS aids new
features so I'll drop a link below if
you want to watch that video it's very
smooth here perform as well it's really
well optimized for Apple's newest
hardware as we would expect but only
time will tell using this phone for a
bit more weather quirks will show up or
bugs need to be fixed or ironed out or
squashed but in the meantime its iOS I
mean you'll notice it's visually not
that different from iOS 7 so let's be
honest if you're coming from any other
iPhone you're gonna feel right at home
here and it's just another iPhone with a
bigger screen so overall that's about it
for now I got to say between the iPhone
6 and a 6 plus the six with the 4.7 inch
screen is I think the one that most
current iPhone users are going to
upgrade to when you hold the 6 plus it's
much bigger but I still have a bunch of
other things to test for when I get to
my full review so the battery life
that's something we don't really know
yet the camera quality I wanna be
testing a lot and be sure to follow on
Twitter and Instagram and Google+ where
I'll be posting photos from the
apparently very good iPhone 6 camera so
definitely follow for that if you'll
also see battery life update so I'll be
posting those as I use this as my daily
driver as well so much more to come
before the full video review of the new
iPhone but this is just my impressions
for now thank you for watching
I'll talk to you guys the next one peace
Oh